good evening thank all of you for being
here this evening i sincerely appreciate
it
i want to start my remarks today by
taking a moment to reflect
on the last few weeks and the covet 19
vaccine rollout that we're going through
as of april 5th we opened vaccine
eligibility to all nevadans
16 years of age and older
we have come so far since when the
vaccines first arrived in our state
in december and i am incredibly proud of
the work
the continued work of the federal state
local partnerships
that are helping us increase access
focus on equity
and ensure nevadans are protected
as of today about 40 percent of nevada
and 16 and older
have started the vaccine process and one
quarter of nevada and 16 and older
are fully vaccinated this is tremendous
news
but we are not done yet we will continue
working around the clock
to make sure we are reaching nevadans
wherever they are at
earlier this year vaccines were widely
before vaccines were widely available i
laid out nevada's roadmap to
recovery safe reopening plan which
included a process for transitioning
the decision-making authority of
mitigation management
of businesses and activities to local
authorities
at the county level as of may first
across the state counties are hard at
work on this process
in consultation with covet 19 response
director caleb gage
and the covet 19 mitigation and
management task force
at the same time at the state level
we've continued
monitoring ongoing covet trends and
evaluating our situation with state
public health officials
it is those conversations and
evaluations that have brought me before
you today
for some exciting updates
for reasons i will walk through in a
moment and based on consultation with
our state health officials
i am pleased to announce that i am very
confident
every county in the state of nevada will
be able to fully reopen at one hundred
percent capacity
by june first the original plan
to transition authority over mitigation
measure members
measures to the counties on may first
remains the same
we are aware that some counties may make
the decision to move 100 percent
capacity as early as may 1st
when they gain the authority others may
not
each county in nevada is unique and has
different factors to consider
rural urban settings community
transmission rates in the area
and vaccine administration among a few
but regardless of the ultimate decisions
each county makes before
makes for the may 1st transition we are
confident that every county will be able
to move to 100
capacity by june 1st
that is nevada's goal and that is the
state level we will do whatever we can
to help counties get there
which leads to another update i'd like
to give today
originally the state planned on keeping
some mandatory measures in place
at the state wide level when authority
transitioned to the counties on may
first
however after extensive conversations
with state health officials
and with the goal to reopen to 100
capacity across nevada by june 1st
we will remove the statewide required
social distancing mandate
as of may 1st this is one of the best
measures i can take as your governor
to increase flexibility and remove
roadblocks for local authorities
as they take over authority of
mitigation measures
this is also a critical step to help
ensure that by june 1st
full capacity means full capacity
to be clear this does not mean the
social distancing will no longer exist
in the state
in fact every health official will agree
it's still an important prevention tool
this just means that the state will no
longer be setting the requirements
the that authority will also now
transition to the counties
so they can make decisions based on what
works best for their local jurisdictions
and when it comes to our biggest
industry the nevada gaming control board
will continue
to maintain authority over gaming areas
including gaming floors
for licensed establishments within the
state of nevada
additionally all applicable
establishments must continue to follow
all requirements outlined
in senate bill 4 from the 32nd special
session
and subsequent regulations i know that
the gaming control board wants to return
to normal just as much as everyone else
does
which is why they've worked so hard with
casino owners
local leaders and employee unions to set
up vaccination sites on gaming
properties
again our state public health officials
feel confident in this planned timeline
to fully reopen by june 1st but they
made it abundantly clear that nevadans
must
continue to get vaccinated and must
continue to wear masks
that's why the state mandate will remain
in place throughout this transition
the masked mandate that is outside of
getting vaccinated
it's still the best tool we have to
prevent the spread
and i want to be clear crystal clear
the mask mandate is a statewide standard
counties have no ability to pass
resolutions or create plans
that attempt to override this mandate
this measure will remain in place
to protect the health and safety of
nevadans to help get the state to a full
reopening
i wish i could give all the vans an
exact timeline
as one we can tuck away our masks but
public health officials
made it clear that in order to reach our
goal of reopening on june 1st
we must make sure nevadans stay massed
it would be irresponsible for me as your
governor
to ignore that advice additionally
it's a common sense bargain if we all
continue to wear masks
we'll help ensure that we can reopen our
state by june 1st
in addition to lifting the statewide
directive on social distancing
requirements
on may 1st and transitioning that
authority to counties
i have another update i'd like to
provide
mitigation member measures within our
education system
have always been separate from the
general public
measures but in an effort to continue
our transitions to local authority
back to normal operations as of may 1st
decisions over mitigation measures
within our schools
will also now be transitioned to county
school districts
and charter school sponsors that
includes
social distancing state superintendent
joan ebert and nevada department of
education have worked tirelessly
with county school districts and the
state public charter school authority to
get our kids back to the classroom
and build an infrastructure to respond
and keep everyone
as safe as possible that included
providing ppe
setting up testing contact tracing and
being one of the first states to
prioritize
educators for vaccinations
and as we know school communities
throughout the state
vary greatly and there are multiple
factors to be considered as each
superintendent
or charter school sponsor and governing
board consults with staff and families
to determine what's safest and to best
ensure healthy learning
and working environments as of may 1st
districts and charter sponsors
will have full authority to make those
decisions
again that doesn't mean mitigation
members measures
such as social distancing will go away
it means each district or charter school
sponsor has the opportunity
to review and make the best decisions
for their schools
as with every decision i've had to make
throughout this pandemic
i know many people will say this is too
soon
others will say it's not soon enough but
today's announcement did not come
without considering a myriad of factors
some of which i want to walk through now
for more than a year as the state we
have been vigilant
thoughtful and deliberative in our
decision-making process
always listening to science and doing
everything we can
to balance the health and safety of
nevadans with the economic impacts
of this pandemic and since our first
case over a year ago
we've learned a lot we've strengthened
partnerships
built relationships tested our public
health
service system and we are coming out of
this stronger
than ever before we initially laid out
goals for a response to prevent an
overwhelming
of our health care infrastructure and to
prevent deaths from this virus
our state mitigation member measures
have been rooted
in these goals because of our efforts
and the work of every nevadan we have
seen significant improvements
of key covid metrics since january all
wire
vaccination rates have increased
over the last month we have seen daily
new cases stabilized
at the lowest we have observed in nearly
a year
with only slight increases since
expanding capacity
limits to 50 percent these small
increases are expected
as we continue to open the economy and
do not currently pose a threat
to our hospital infrastructure as we
continue to vaccinate more nevadans
we will continue to strengthen our
defense against future surges
and protect our vital public health
infrastructure
goal we've had all along health care
providers have greatly improved
treatments
and our incredible hospitals and health
care workers have developed
management efforts these are noteworthy
milestones that we can expect to play a
significant role
in ensuring that nevada's hospital
infrastructure
never again reaches the strain that was
experienced during the winter surge
i want to take a moment to thank
nevada's medical personnel
they faced immense stress pressure and
unimaginable hardships for over a year
but even when tested our health care
workers and hospitals
never broke this test of our system
shows how strong we are and that we can
problem-solve
and that across the state to support our
residents
in addition the progress made within our
hospitals we've also managed to build a
stronger public health infrastructure
to help manage going forward
state health officials emergency
managers local health
authorities and partners statewide have
made so much progress
to build a testing and contact tracing
structure
to match the burden of the disease in
communities
we now have capacity to conduct contact
tracing
and disease investigation at a much
higher level than ever before
it's easy to forget how difficult it was
to get a covet test at the start of the
pandemic
since now kova testing is readily
accessible in communities throughout
nevada
i'm confident these response efforts
that we built together over the last
year will remain in place thanks to
increase in extended
federal funding we have also prioritized
and approved our processes
and data and now while cases are lower
counties are able to use this knowledge
respond quickly
and identify where interventions need to
occur
this helps our efforts to slow the
spread
we also know how important this is to
protect our seniors and vulnerable
populations
from this virus a key factor that was
considered when discussing
the june 1st goal nevada skilled nursing
facilities
long-term care and other residential
centers move
quickly in our state's early response to
improved precaution
and work to protect nevadans
in march the covet tracking project that
follows kova data nationwide
reported that nevada has the lowest
percentage of covit-19 deaths that
occurred in long-term care facilities
in the continental united states this
should make us all proud
i trust that our seniors in vulnerable
nevadans are in good hands and the focus
on protecting residents
will remain going forward in addition to
all this progress the introduction
of covet vaccines have changed the game
i have visited some of our covet 19
vaccine sites across the state
when you see people who are vaccinated
and you hear the sigh of
relief that they have you know that
people are feeling safer and more
optimistic about the future
these incredible efforts on the ground
and the focus early on in our
vaccination plan to protect as many
nevadans as possible
as efficiently as we could is showing
signs of success the vaccines have been
shown to be effective
against serious illness and death that
is why we prioritize our vulnerable
population
to receive some of the first doses
shipped to the state in december
including older nevadans we know that
covet 19 impacts our vulnerable
population particularly hard
sadly 83 percent of covet 19 deaths
are among those aged 60 and older
in november and december 61 of
hospitalizations
were among those aged 60 and above
but due to the hard work of so many as
of today
65 percent of nevadans aged 60 and older
and 75 percent of nevada 70 and older
have initiated or completed vaccination
and as more older nevadans get
vaccinated the proportion of confirmed
covet 19 cases
within these age groups has decreased
this and other updates i've provided are
some of the reasons our state
health officials feel comfortable
setting the goal at a full reopening
to 100 capacity on june 1st
vaccines are helping us protect those
most at risk
of hospitalization and death and the
progress continues
as of april 5th nevada is receiving an
average of 74 000
covet vaccine doses each week which will
allow for more appointments and more
providers that have vaccines
for their patients another reason we
felt comfortable with the june 1st goal
because by that date vaccination
opportunities will have been open and
available for all nevadans 16 and older
for nearly two full months as more doses
become available week by week the nevada
state immunization
program will continue to work with local
leaders to focus on equity and increase
accessibility by adding more convenient
ways for people to be vaccinated
whether it is a drive-through or your
local pharmacy
nevada we're closer to the end than we
are to the beginning
we are on our path to recovery one shot
in the arm
at a time so to recap
on may 1st authority over mitigation
members will transition to local control
at the county level an authority over
mitigation members in schools will
transition back to county school
districts
including social distancing each county
will be approving their plans in the
near future
and today i've set statewide goal that
all counties be open to 100
capacity by june 1st
a safe and responsible reopening like
what i have laid out
is the path forward to bringing back our
state economy
helping our small businesses bringing
back conventions
and getting nevadans back to work it's
how we ensure nevada doesn't spend the
next
decade crawling forward but instead
sprinting forward to create a better
healthier
and more prosperous safe for all of us
in order to reach this goal everyone
must play their part
the state will keep the mask mandate in
place and support all vaccination
and response efforts counties must
evaluate transmission in their areas
and make best decisions on how to
protect their residents
starting may 1st businesses must
continue to operate safely
and protect our economic future
finally it comes down to every
individual
nevadan every resident of this state
every resident has a stake in the game
wear a mask
stay home when you're sick get tested
and most importantly get a vaccine as
soon as possible
it doesn't stop with you call or text
five people you know
family members neighbors friends share
appointment information
for vaccines help a neighbor's schedule
or give them a ride if you're not sure
where to start
go to nvcovid fighter.org for
information
or call the hotline at 800-401-0946
we know this virus is still present in
our communities
and we must also accept the fact that
kovat will continue to be present into
the future
similar to other viruses that we are
familiar with
but what we do know now that will allow
us to turn to more normal
nevada lifestyle on june 1st
and focus on a strong economic recovery
remaining vigilant wearing a mask and
most importantly
getting vaccinated as soon as possible
nevada
we can do this let's meet the goal
let's come back stronger together
thank you all and i will now take a few
questions
hey there governor thank you so much for
doing this today thank you uh brian with
uh two news just for the record um
so we're starting to see other countries
unfortunately go back in the lockdown
and even some states
uh you know their governors coming out
pleading with their citizens
to take it easy and be safer what do you
think nevadans
have done to reach this point of 100
reopening
and at what point since we are starting
to see some other strains uh
come in that are even more contagious at
what point could we get to to where the
state
takes back control from the counties i
am confident in the
residents of the state of nevada they've
done an incredible job to this point
in following our directives the vast
majority of residents in the state of
nevada
the best two things that we can do to
make sure that we don't take a step back
backward or get your vaccine as soon as
you're eligible to get it which is now
for everybody 16 or older
as soon as you can get an appointment
and continue to wear a mask
different communities are going to have
different standards and whatnot for
reopening
because different counties are different
rural and urban and
the setting and whatnot so i'm confident
that if our residents follow these two
simple
guidelines wear a mask and get your
vaccine we're going to be
is there any type of fine positivity
number any rate increase or
mortality increase that we see that this
state has a
has a mind on taking control back over
from no i do not have a trigger figure
for any of those things
i'm confident that if we maintain those
two things and we keep getting
every day that goes by every hour that
goes by that we get another shot in
somebody's arm
is making it better for us and i'm
confident that you know
residents will continue to do that and
by may 1st june 1st we're going to be in
better shape
does the news of the johnson johnson
vaccine taking a step back on that does
that change any of these plans at all
no it doesn't change any of the plans at
all i mean we're waiting to see
how the review on the j j vaccine goes
we had a white house call this morning
with all the governors and we went over
this with a great deal of specificity
we can let the progress through the
process through the cdc and the review
go through
what it needs to go through and they'll
make a decision we'll follow the
supporting them
hi governor thanks for doing this you
call this a common sense bargain
is this a response or attempt at
compromise after rural counties like
nine hours plans to reopen to 100
without masks on may 1st
no i'm going to reiterate this one more
time they cannot open without masks
no it's a bargain to you know when you
you're dealing with you know three
million residents in the state of nevada
who i want to re-emphasize have done an
incredible job getting us at this point
we are only here we're in better shape
than a lot of states are
because our residents vast majority our
residents
have gone along with the program and
have tried to help the bargain i'm
making is a bargain with the citizens
the residents of the state of nevada if
you continue to do what you've done
which is get your vaccines when possible
you get appointment
and wear your mask we're going to be in
good shape and we'll all move forward
better and stronger
we need to get people back to work and
that's what we're focused on doing
so you know that county officials have a
time to criticize you throughout the
pandemic
for leaving them out of various planning
processes why make this announcement in
the middle of a two days task force
about these very decisions since it
looked like most were on track to do
this anyways
is it a matter of who gets credit for
reopening the state
it's not a matter who gets credit i mean
we made a plan to to give this authority
over to the counties on may first some
counties will do it some will not do it
we've got three weeks left here
businesses have asked for time to plan
and to make accommodations and in
consultation with our medical experts
i'm not interested in who gets credit
you know we've been dealing with this
for
13 months i've been dealing with this
now you get a lot of people now suddenly
again everybody's going to second guess
or be a monday morning quarterback we
have made the best decisions possible
and i'm excited to be in the position
that we're at today i really am
it's the first really good news that
i've been able to deliver in a long time
and i'm hopeful that our residents take
it that way and we can all be moved
forward stronger
thank you thank you
just a quick simple yes or no question
and then i have a quick question about
covid but we saw today a
death penalty abolition bill come into
the assembly if that bill lands on your
desk
would you sign it okay i was expecting
this question
in light of what happened in the
assembly and i'm going to prepare i'm
going to read a prepared statement that
i have
i'm not going to take any follow-up
questions but i'm going to leave it as a
statement
okay you can have a copy question after
this but no more death penalty questions
what i've said on the record in the past
has not changed
under most circumstances i'm opposed to
capital punishment
i know there have been wrongful
convictions i know there are significant
costs associated with capital punishment
and more but as also said on the record
in the past there are incredibly severe
situations
that may warrant consideration of
capital punishment
but i believe overall it should be
sought and used less often
i was on the ground the night and the
morning after
one october i was there i talked to
families whose loved ones were victims
the experiences of victims family
members are always on my mind
just like the majority of nevadans they
consider this issue
that weighs heavily on me which is why i
have a hard time with the idea
of a complete abolishment of the death
penalty
i'll continue watching this bill as
governor
i have responsibility to be considerate
of all these factors
while i weigh any legislation that could
get to my desk
and then we've seen some small increases
in case numbers and hospitalizations in
recent days and the state as well as the
rest of the world
is in a precarious position right now as
the vaccines race against the variants
why are you making this announcement
today when we don't know what's going to
happen in the coming weeks
we never know what's going to happen in
the coming weeks if i waited a month to
make this announcement we wouldn't know
what's coming in the coming weeks after
that
i am so incredibly proud and
appreciative of the work
that nevadans have done small businesses
have sacrificed tremendously
our labor force has sacrificed
tremendously educators front line
workers students parents everybody a
sacrifice
there has to be a light at the end of
the tunnel there has to be an
opportunity for us to get back to our
better normal and i think this is the
opportunity and i'm confident
with those two situations in place that
people continue to wear a mask
and they avail themselves of the
opportunity to get a vaccine we're going
to be in a better position
and then if we do see cases increasing
would that then would that then
necessitate the state stepping in again
i will continue as we move forward to
listen to my medical advisory team
you know they are not bringing that up
at this time i mean anything could
possibly happen i talked to
my friend gretchen whitmer pretty
regular and i know what she's gone
through in the last couple weeks
i cannot make a commitment on what's
going to happen two weeks or four weeks
or eight weeks down the line and i don't
have a specific
trigger number whether it's
hospitalizations or test positivities or
whatever it might be
but you look back last year november
december we had twenty two hundred
twenty three hundred
cases in the hospital i mean we had a
parking garage
made into a hospital uh room here at
renault i'm in southern nevada they were
using convention center
different areas we're down now to around
300
statewide hospitalizations because
everything's improved
and every day that goes by that we
vaccinate as i said we get 70 000
doses a week you know it's another ten
thousand eleven thousand doses a day
are going into people's arms every day
that goes by
it should be improving for us thank you
thank you are you concerned about the
pause on the jansen vaccine creating
more hesitation among people who are
already on the fence about getting it
especially in the rurals
we have the fema truck now yeah you mean
about getting the johnson virus or
vaccine well i got the johnson vaccine
myself
so i i didn't have any hesitation about
it i'm confident the cdc is going to
analyze this
i think they did the right thing they
started to see a pattern they saw six
cases out of
seven million doses that were given out
they're researching to see if there were
more cases
involved they're going to have a
thorough review of this which is
how vaccines are evaluated and how they
move forward i think they're making the
right call and we're going to follow
their guidance but
i think would be premature to speculate
on what ifs let's see what happens
tomorrow
when they begin this review and how long
it takes and hopefully they'll
get back to us did you take this pause
into account when making this decision
today
we took everything into account when
making this decision today
i mean i don't know if this pause is
going to last a day if it's going to
last a week if it's going to last the
month
that will remain for the medical experts
to find to divine
but i am confident with the position
that we're in the johnson johnson
uh the jj vaccines that we're getting a
relatively small percentage of our
overall
vaccines that we're getting the pfizer
and modern vaccines have been
absolutely incredible they might cause
some
minor discomfort for people they might
get fatigued they might get a sore iron
they might get some nausea that sort of
thing
but those are signs that the vaccine is
working
and i'm confident that the more people
get them the better off we're going to
be and
we'll be back to using all the vaccines
that are available to us
and then we've got a kind of an end date
now for
state statewide statewide social
distancing mandates
you said that the mass mandate is going
to stay is there a goal or an end date
in your mind when that mass mandate
might lift yeah as soon as i can get as
many people as stated about a vaccinated
as possible that's when we're going to
be able
to but i don't know what that date's
going to be if you're talking about a
calendar date
it's important to me that we protect our
residents we protect our workers
our frontline workers and we also open
our economy back up i mean i need to get
conventions i need to get events coming
back into town
into the state i need to get people back
to work as a result of those
and i think these uh openings are going
to make that a lot more
realistic and a lot more speedy
appreciate it that's it
thanks y'all